the pandemic is gathering pace over in
Brazil the death toll they're now
approaching two-and-a-half thousand that
is the highest figure in Latin America
and the president's handling of the
outbreak has proved highly controversial
but over the weekend major cities saw
protests in support of jayapal Sonora
and against local curfews a sweet person
ARRA sacked his Health Minister for
demanding tougher lockdown measures the
President himself has resisted any form
of shutdown and repeatedly downplayed
the dangers at the virus mania that all
containment measures have happened at a
local level the firing of the Health
Minister has prompted a mixed reaction
among Brazilians I see this as an
ordinary process in government the
Health Minister was out of step with the
policies being led by the president and
I think he got caught up in all the hype
as a minister he has to be accountable
for his actions and the same goes for
anyone in public office or things just
don't work we still trust the outgoing
Health Minister and we hope that the new
minister can build on what is done when
you look at the situation the government
is in now it's going to be difficult to
change anything or make any progress I
don't see that this move will make any
difference because of all the corruption
and the government Moulson Arrow's
administration is corrupt in the
Brazilian city of Manaus hospitals have
been overloaded with curve in 19
patients videos have been posted online
and broadcast on national TV showing
dead bodies in hospital wards along side
living patients who are fighting for
their survival and those images have
caused widespread shock and anger but
despite the rising death toll in Brazil
president bowls enero says that the
country must push to reopen its economy
Yuda I know life is priceless but the
economy and employment must return to
normal Brazilian journalist Bruna aldmer
says that president balsa narrow is
prioritizing the interests of big
business over public health
related to the financial lobbies which
have supported him since the beginning
those groups are against social
isolation because they don't want a baby
obvious facts account for emergency
measures both Romero
also makes political accounts and
believe that criticizing social
isolation he is going to be upheld by
those who have fear to get without a job
and income he wants to take this
opportunity with the kernel oil prices
to empower himself he is not worried
about people's life is not worried about
public health
you